former judge gabrielle union says she
was mistreated
and current host terry crews says he
regrets how he responded to the
situation
you recently apologized to gabrielle
union because you said you didn't
support her enough explain that
i was the wrong guy to ask about being
on
agt because i love it i can't speak on
behalf of any racism comments
that was never my experience on
america's got talent
i had to understand that i'm looking at
this thing from a lens of male
privilege where men and women are
treated differently on sets
when you're wrong you gotta just say hey
i apologize i'm sorry
let me get back in here and let's do
this right gabrielle what do you think
that was amazing agt will return with
live shows in august five months after
production was shut down
for covet 19. you guys ready
how are you going to shoot the show well
we are guinea pigs right now
yeah you are we're shooting judge cuts
but it's going to be socially distant
we're not going to be with people
literally they're going to set us up and
let us go
we're going to be by ourselves turn on
the camera you do your thing
and we're going to make the show happen
from there and even the acts
are going to be distant so the acts are
going to be quarantined
[Music]
on tonight's episode eric stonestreet
fills in for heidi and reunites with his
modern family co-star
sophia vergara so i get a call
9 45 in the morning from my people and
they said you've been asked to
sub in for heidi she has a cold i was
like is sophia okay with it i mean it's
her brand new job she may not want to
see me yet
no no no she she wants you to come howie
mandel he was so funny when i sat down
and goes
you touch your face a lot it's not you
need to stop touching your face so much
like well because i feel sweat coming
down he's like use your jacket but
you seriously you need to stop touching
your face so much